[Musik]
lassen sie uns jetzt das erreichte nicht
verspielen und ein rückschlag ist mahnt
die kanzlerin in der korona krise und
kritisiert die lockerungen in manchen
bundesländern seien zu forsch mehr geld
für kurzarbeiter weniger mehrwertsteuer
in der gastronomie union und spd einigen
sich auf weitere hilfen auch schüler
sollen profitieren
und so plant die bundesliga ihr comeback
mit tausenden corona tests und ohne fans
will der profi fußball zurück ins
stadion
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
donnerstag guten abend hinein die
bundeskanzlerin stellt die deutschen auf
eine lange zeit der beschränkungen ein
regierungserklärung im bundestag heute
wir werden noch lange mit diesem virus
leben müssen sagt angela merkel
und dann hat sie eine mahnung an
einzelne ministerpräsidenten die sie
scharf kritisiert für aus ihrer sicht
voreilige lockerungen wie schnell
sollten die beschränkungen
zurückgefahren werden darüber tobt eine
debatte im täglichen leben von uns allen
dazu gleich und in der politik damit
beginnt heute abend daniel trotzen
kaum eine politische entscheidung sei
ihr jesus schwer gefallen wie die
einschränkungen der persönlichen
freiheitsrechte so die kanzlerin
und dies müsse nun immer wieder
begründet werden aber disziplin jetzt
sei langfristig zentral
niemand redet gerne aber es ist die
wahrheit wir leben nicht in der endphase
der pandemie soll man sondern immer noch
an ihrem anfang
wir werden noch lange mit diesem virus
leben
er wurde danach das ende der
parteiübergreifenden einmütigkeit
aushält der regierung vor zielvorgaben
verändert zu haben und
handlungsempfehlungen etwa bei
schutzmasken
zudem sieht er die öffentliche debatte
gefährdet zitiert die sorge dass wir in
unserem land über öffnung diskutieren
will mindestens unter einem moralischen
rechtfertigungsdruck gerät das man diese
fragen nun im parlament diskutieren
begrüßt die spd-fraktion sie stützt
merkels kurs auf der anderen seite frau
bundeskanzlerin sind es die
demokratischen zumutung mit denen man
sich auseinandersetzen muss und deswegen
ist es richtig dass viele in diesem land
die berechtigten fragen nach der
einschränkung der rechtsgüter stellen
und ob sie verhältnismäßig sind die afg
aus der zu beginn der krise noch der
vorwurf zu später maßnahmen kam
konzentriert sich in ihrer kritik nun
auf die gegenteilige richtung
[Applaus]
länder wie südkorea taiwan und singapur
ohne lockdown durch die krise gekommen
sind nicht das einsperren der gesamten
bevölkerung ist die lösung sondern der
schutz der risiko die kanzlerin und
treibt unterdessen vor allem die sorge
das erreichte zu verspielen durch zu
weitgehende lockerungen in den einzelnen
ländern
ich trage die beschlüsse die bund und
länder am mittwoch letzter woche
getroffen haben aus voller überzeugung
mit doch ihre umsetzung seither bereitet
ihr sohn sie wirkt auch nicht in teilen
sie erforscht um nicht zu sagen zuvor
hieran knüpft auch kritik der linken
ihre krisenpolitik steuert jetzt immer
mehr auf einen flickenteppich zu und da
sind herr söder und herr laschet leider
ein stückweit verhaltensauffällig dänen
müssen sich ihre kritik als allererstes
sagen zudem brauche es massive hilfen
für die ärmsten eine forderung auch von
ihm nach der krise brauche ist ein
großes grün ausgerichtetes
konjunkturpaket bis dahin aber disziplin
man sollte einfach aufhören die eigene
freiheit schlichtweg zu verwechseln
im recht des stärkeren nämlich das ist
eine vulgäre form von freiheit
es war die rückkehr der harten debatte
heute im plenum durchaus mit ein wenig
polemik vor allem aber
auseinandersetzung in der sache und für
die analyse auch heute abend guten abend
an theo koll in berlin theo das war doch
ein ungewöhnlicher öffentlicher rüffel
von angela merkel was genau stört die
kanzlerin nun sie stört es einige
bundesländer bei den eröffnungs
maßnahmen föderale eigenheiten man
könnte auch sagen föderalen eigensinn
leben und sich nicht an das gemeinsam
vereinbarte halten sie hat die sorge
dass das schon erreichte wieder
verspielt und ein rückschlag riskiert
wird er ist sie eigentlich ganz die
physikerin die beklagte aktuelle
entscheidung getroffen werden müssen
aber auf der grundlage von
infektionszahlen die immer zehn oder
zwölf tage alt sind auch daher heute die
mehrfache mahnung zur vorsicht und
disziplin alles andere hält sie glaube
ich vielleicht sind oder teil dieser
berühmten öffnungs diskussions orgie
jetzt scheint es ja grob gesagt zwei
lager in diesem land zu geben und in der
politik
kann man die beiden seiten dort
beschreiben ich glaube es gibt sogar
plötzlich noch mehr unterschiedliche
seiten gleich an vielen stellen ist ja
die zeit der anfänglichen einmütigkeit
und auch dominanz der exekutive vorbei
die bundesländer weichen unterschiedlich
stark vom beschlossenen öffnungskurs ab
die opposition hat heute sehr deutlich
das ende der einmütigkeit angekündigt
und selbst der chef der unionsfraktion
hat heute ziemlich auf den tisch gehauen
und der bundesregierung alleingänge
vorgeworfen wenn man im corona bild
bleiben möchte dann hat das politische
system jetzt die erste infektions phase
hinter sich und bildet ab sofort
verstärkt widerstandskräfte aus der
herzlichen dank die debatte in der
politik war das und die debatte läuft
natürlich auch bei uns alle jeden tag
und es gibt viel verunsicherung und
immer noch viele offene fragen bei jedem
einzelnen
ein beispiel die masken da ist die
situation jetzt so sachsen machte am
montag den anfang die anderen folgen
jetzt ab kommender woche gilt fast
überall beim einkaufen und den bus und
bahn mundschutz auf ausnahme berlin
hier gibt es für geschäfte keine pflicht
deutschland braucht jetzt also
abermillionen von masken und da stellt
sich die frage geben uns masken
möglicherweise ein falsches gefühl von
sicherheit
antoine kuscheln münchen heute
nachmittag das schöne wetter zieht die
menschen ins freie viel los rund um den
englischen garten abstand halten nicht
immer bei allen lässt die disziplin etwa
nach viele machen sich deswegen sorgen
aus jedem winkel jemand kriecht und sagt
er weiß es besser als ist die regierung
sagt ich finde das einfach nur
beunruhigend für die bevölkerung
verunsichert 1 schon wie es jetzt
weitergeht wenn sich lockern ob da noch
mehr
ob dann noch mehr leute unterwegs sind
ob sie sich alle daran halten
viel los war heute auch in rostock und
die hansestadt meldet einen erfolg im
kampf gegen das virus seit zwei wochen
wurde hier kein neuer corona fall
registriert es geht also vorwärts aber
trotzdem kein grund zur entwarnung wir
dürfen nicht jetzt in unseren schutz
bemühungen nachlassen und es kann
natürlich auch noch
eine zwei drei weitere wellen kommen wir
wissen nicht wie sich die nächsten
wochen und monate gestalten das ist uns
klar
aber wir haben heute einmal einen grund
und wir sehen ist dass unsere maßnahmen
wirken
zu den maßnahmen gehört auch der mund
nasenschutz ab montag gilt in
deutschland die masken pflicht aber
woher bekomme ich jetzt ein mundschutz
fragen sich viele kaufen selber nähen
oder doch einen schal vors gesicht in
hannover verkaufte heute ein unternehmen
masken in der innenstadt schlange stehen
für die bürgerpflicht
also ich werde mir versuchen stoffmasken
zu ergattern
die man halt auch waschen können weil
die einmal masken die muss man ja immer
gleich wegschmeißen was vielleicht auch
angenehmer als irgendwie so eine
papiermaske oder sinnlich erotische
maske ein tipp noch wer einen mundschutz
hat sollte ihn nicht beim autofahren
tragen wenn die maske das gesicht
verdeckt kann das teuer werden bis zu 60
euro denn das gesicht eines autofahrers
muss immer erkennbar sein
interessante zusatzinformationen
einkaufen also bald nur noch mit maske
doch die leute haben offenbar gar keine
große lust geld auszugeben
die kauflaune ist massiv eingebrochen
ein historischer tiefstand sagen die
konsumforscher der gfk in ihrer
aktuellen studie
kurzarbeit und die angst vor
arbeitslosigkeit zeigten wirkung die
folge wegen der korona krise traue sich
kaum noch jemand teure anschaffungen wie
autos oder möbeln zu planen und dennoch
heißt es bei volkswagen in deutschland
heute zurück ans band nach rund fünf
wochen kroner stillstand läuft die
autoproduktion langsam wieder an den
anfang macht das werk in zwickau
zunächst mit nur einer schicht pro tag
und 50 golfs auch im motorenwerk
chemnitz ging es los ab montag sollen
dann der stammsitz in wolfsburg und
weitere werke folgen
vw setzt dabei auf verschärfte
hygienestandards und strikte
abstandsregeln lange beratungen
vergangenen nacht jetzt hat die
bundesregierung weitere hilfsmaßnahmen
beschlossen und dazu zählt ein höheres
kurzarbeitergeld aktuell gibt es 60
prozent des bisherigen nettolohns von
der arbeitsagentur ab dem vierten monat
kurzarbeit sollen das künftig sie
6 prozent sein und vom siebten monat an
sogar 80 prozent
eltern bekommen jeweils sieben prozent
mehr
und es gibt noch weitere neue hilfen
karl hinterleitner
der staat nimmt gilt in die hand viel
geld zehn zusätzliche milliarden für
corona hilfen
das müsse sein und deutschland könne es
sich auch leisten meint olaf scholz in
der sendung was nun
wer waren unter 60 prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung als staatsschulden
aber wir werden jetzt auf 75 steigen
nachdem was wir jetzt berechnen können
wo das genau endet das werden wir sehen
in der letzten krise war 80 ist das
zeigt mir sind ziemlich stark was unsere
möglichkeit das aktuelle hilfspaket
umfasst neben der erhöhung des
kurzarbeitergeldes vor allem die
gastronomie für sie wird ein jahr lang
die mehrwertsteuer gesenkt von juli 2020
bis ende juni 2021 zahlen restaurants
hotels und lokale statt 19 nur noch
sieben prozent
und es gibt 500 millionen euro
zusätzlich für digitales lernen daraus
bekommen bedürftige schüler jeweils 150
euro zuschuss für computerausstattung
teure maßnahmen und ein wechsel auf die
zukunft aber notwendig und richtig
meinen wirtschaftsexperten
es sieht auf den ersten blick so aus als
würden wir der nächsten generation
furchtbare lasten aufbürden aber man
muss nüchtern sehen wenn der staat das
jetzt nicht tun würde dann wäre die
krise noch tiefer es würde noch mehr
wohlstand zerstört und am ende hätte die
nächste generation auch diese last zu
tragen das heißt am ende liegt
entschlossenes handeln gg halten gegen
die krise so weit das geht auch im
interesse der jungen generation das ist
unser aller interesse
ob am ende das geld wirklich reicht
hängt davon ab wie lange die krise
dauert
klar ist die politik kämpft mit allen
finanziellen mitteln ja viel dreht sich
ums geld in der korona krise bettina
schausten und peter frey haben da einige
fragen an den bundesfinanzminister was
nun herr scholz direkt nach uns gegen 19
uhr 25
in deutschland hat sich die so wichtige
reproduktions zahl nicht verändert
weiterhin infiziert ein virus träger im
schnitt 0,9 andere menschen schätzt das
robert koch institut im vergleich zu
gestern ist
zahl der neuinfektionen gestiegen anfang
des monats waren es fast 7000 täglich
heute sind es noch rund 2400 menschen
die sich neu infiziert haben
insgesamt kommt die johns hopkins
universität auf mehr als 151.000
bestätigte corona fälle in deutschland
stand vor einer halben stunde davon
gelten gut 100 3000 betroffene als
genießen und 5354 menschen sind in
verbindung mit dem virus gestorben
hinter diesen zahlen stehen die
menschlichen schicksale dieser
beispiellosen krise hinter den zahlen
jetzt steckt die angst die umgeht
überall in europa nämlich dass die
wirtschaft in die knie geht und die
fähigkeit von manchen staaten zu helfen
gleich mit bis zu 2 billionen euro
insgesamt schwer vorstellbar diese summe
aber das ist der gesamtumfang des
hilfsprogramms dass die staats und
regierungschefs heute diskutieren daran
hängt auch die zukunft der europäischen
union selbst stefan leifert hier wäre es
heute wohl rund gegangen doch hier gab
es heute nichts zu sehen nichts zu hören
der raum in dem sich sonst europas
konflikte bündeln verweist verlassen
verriegelt die eu verhandelt ihre
schicksalsfragen im online modus schon
zum vierten mal tagen die
regierungschefs sind videochat konsens
ist bereits 1 500 milliarden
sofortprogramm
gestritten wird nun über einen
wiederaufbau von für europas wirtschaft
nach der krise die rede ist von einer
billion euro
eine eins mit 12 0 die länder des südens
wollen einen fonds der bedingungslos
zuschüsse gibt und mit corona bonds
befüllt wird
die nordeuropäer bevorzugen kredite die
zurückgezahlt werden und einen fonds der
an den eu-haushalt gekoppelt ist wer wie
viel zu welchen bedingungen bekommt
alles noch offen so laut der streit auch
ausgetragen wird so leise ist es heute
in brüssel eu viertel
aber anne gellinek ist für uns dort ein
abend das alles wird ja von manchen
bereits als schicksalsstunde für die
existenz der eu beschrieben zeigt sich
dass bei der eu in brüssel
also wie es im moment aussieht wird die
schicksalsstunde europas noch einmal
verschoben
die 27 staats und regierungschefs sitzen
noch zusammen und beraten über den
billionenschweren wiederaufbau fonds ein
kompromiss bei der finanzierung wird in
umrissen sichtbar
man wird sich offenbar nicht auf
eurobonds einigen können sondern den
neuen topf er im eu-haushalt andocken
die eu kommission könnte anleihen
ausgeben für die die mitgliedstaaten
garantieren ob die südeuropäer dem am
ende zustimmen ist offen genauso wie
viele andere fragen wie viel geld soll
eigentlich in diesem wiederaufbau fonds
sein wofür soll das geld ausgegeben
werden und unter welchen bedingungen
bekommen besonders betroffene länder
kredite oder gelder die sie nicht
zurückzahlen müssen
bei all dem sind die mitgliedstaaten
noch sehr weit auseinander so weit dass
es noch nicht mal eine gemeinsame
abschlusserklärung der 27 geben wird
sondern eher einen arbeitsauftrag an die
eu kommission jetzt mal einen konkreten
vorschlag zu machen wenn man es positiv
sehen will kann man sagen
die eu hat sich heute abend nicht weiter
zerstritten
aber ein kraftvolles signal europas
sieht wohl anders aus
an den gellinek zdf brüssel dankeschön
für hunderte millionen muslime beginnt
in den nächsten stunden der fastenmonat
ramadan natürlich auch unter nie
dagewesenen umständen ramadan das heißt
zwischen sonnenaufgang und
sonnenuntergang verzichten gläubiger auf
essen und trinken
diesmal ist noch mehr verzichten das
fastenbrechen im großen kreis wird es in
den meisten muslimischen ländern nicht
geben und auch nicht das nächtliche
gebet in der moschee reisen in die
heiligen stätten des islam sind verboten
uli gack zeigt was das etwa für ägypten
bedeutet es ist der tag vor sammer dann
trotz ausgangs beschränkungen scheint es
so als wäre die korona krise lichtjahre
von k
entfernt als gäbe es keine
ansteckungsgefahr
ja wir fürchten uns solche
menschenmassen sind völlig unnötig man
muss abstand halten
denn kontakten mit anderen meiden denn
noch hunderttausende sind unterwegs in
kairo um letzte besorgungen für die
feiertage zu machen und doch kaum
vorfreude auf ramadan
der grund die moscheen sind geschlossen
ramadan das sind die museen das ist
islam das ist das fast und wir fühlen
nichts von alledem salat frommer muslim
und gelehrter der rachman gemeinde
bedauert dass deswegen corona keine
gemeinsamen gebete kein gemeinsames
fastenbrechen gibt auch unsere moschee
ist geschlossen das macht uns traurig
und betrübt
es ist für alle muslime sehr hart aber
bei gott diese krise wird vorübergehen
keine vorfreude auf ramadan
beispielsweise im motor der stadtteil in
kairo hier gab es corona verdacht dann
zwei wochen quarantäne ausgangssperre
für 40.000 ungezählte haben soll jobs
und einkommen verloren
hilfsorganisationen hatten
lebensmittelpakete für bedürftige im
ramadan viel mehr als in den jahren
zuvor und dabei lebte jede dritte
ägyptische volk oder unter der
armutsgrenze
weitere wichtige nachrichten ein
historischer prozess hat in koblenz
begonnen zum ersten mal überhaupt müssen
sich vertreter des syrischen assad
regimes vor gericht verantworten vorwurf
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
angeklagt sind zwei männer sie sollen
als geheimdienstoffiziere menschen
gefoltert haben
nach ihrer flucht nach deutschland waren
sie hier von mutmaßlichen opfern
wiedererkannt worden
julia schröter und marion geiger ein
stück geschichte heute in koblenz
erstmals sitzen handlanger des assad
regimes auf der anklagebank an war er
nach deutschland geflohen weil er später
zur opposition übergelaufen sein will
soll in syrien kommandant eines
foltergefängnisses gewesen sein
ihm wird unter anderem
58 fahrer mord zur last gelegt er soll
ein helfer gewesen sein
insgesamt sollen im tatzeitraum bis zu
4000 personen oder mindestens 4000
personen befördert worden sein
passiert sein soll all das als während
des arabischen frühlings auch in syrien
zehntausende auf die straße gingen
brutal versuchten us getreue den wunsch
nach demokratie und meinungsfreiheit zu
ersticken
in koblenz treten opfer von damals als
nebenkläger auf haben viele leute und
vor allem auch unsere mandanten sehr
lange darauf gewartet dass es endlich
losgeht
für sie ist es eine große
herausforderung gewesen aus dem schatten
zu treten und das erste mal überhaupt
über diese taten zu sprechen
eine anklage wegen verbrechen die von
nicht deutschen im ausland begangen
wurden
möglich macht das ein spezielles
rechtsprinzip menschen die verbrechen
gegen die menschlichkeit begangen haben
zum beispiel systematische folter und
soll in keinem land der welt vor
strafverfolgung sicher sein das sagt das
weltrechtsprinzip das gilt in
deutschland und deswegen ist heute hier
vor dem olg koblenz die anklage gegen
die syrischen geheimdienst mitarbeiter
möglich der prozess wegen starts folter
in syrien menschenrechtler sprechen von
einem meilenstein für an war er könnte
er mit einer lebenslangen haftstrafe
enden heute vor 75 jahren wurde das
konzentrationslager frost flossenbürg
befreit vor ort nur stilles gedenken
wegen corona die bayerische
landtagspräsidentin ilse aigner legte
einen kranz nieder
gleichzeitig gab es für überlebende und
deren angehörige einen gedenkakt via
video schalte bis ende des zweiten
weltkriegs waren in dem lager in der
oberpfalz mehr als 100.000
kriegsgefangene inhaftiert etwa 30.000
häftlinge kamen uns leben und jetzt ganz
anderes thema der fußball ja es gibt die
noch auch wenn der spielbetrieb ruht die
chefs der deutschen fußball liga machten
aber heute klar sie seien bereit den
rest der saison in der ersten und
zweiten liga wieder anzupfeifen boris
büchler dfl-boss christian seifert und
die profiklubs sagen ja zum neustart
doch hinter den kulissen beschäftigt
sich die milliarden schwere branche auch
mit einem worst case szenario denn bei
einem abbruch der saison droht vielen
klubs eine finanzielle schieflage
insofern wäre die bundesliga dann
irgendwann auch ein kollateralschaden
dieser corona krise die dfl task force
um den mediziner tim meyer hat heute ein
hügel jene konzept vorgestellt wonach
das stadion in drei zonen eingeteilt
wird in jedem bereich dürfen maximal nur
circa 100 personen zeitgleich anwesend
sein
insgesamt aber nicht mehr als 300 die
teams sollen zudem getrennt anreisen
weitere vorgaben keine handshakes auf
der bank nur jeden zweiten oder dritten
sitz benutzen und virtuelle
pressekonferenzen und alle müssen vor
jedem spiel getestet werden
die kommentare die sicher teilweise auch
dann auch das konzept beziehen und oder
auf die tatsache dass wir testen und
dass wir menschen tests wegnehmen obwohl
das nach bestem wissen und gewissen und
stand heute einfach nicht der fall ist
trotzdem hält sich dieses hält sich
diese these bis saisonende müsste 25.000
mal getestet werden für nicht wenige
kritiker würde damit der fußball eine
sonderrolle einnehmen
ich sehe nicht warum bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen ob die nun sportler
sind warum die rückkehr routinemäßig
gescreent werden sollten
das konzept für eine fortsetzung der
saison liegt auf dem tisch eine
entscheidung aber wird frühestens
nächste woche fallen
wenn etwas lang erwartetes neu
eingeweiht werden kann dann braucht das
symbolische bilder auch in corona zeiten
norwegen hatte da diese idee
verkehrsminister knut orior rede
eröffnet das größte verkehrsprojekt des
landes und zwar ohne sich vom
schreibtisch wegzubewegen 53 kilometer
lang ist das rief fast atlantik
tunnelsystem abschluss der zeremonie der
verkehrsminister durchschneidet das
symbolische flatterband an seinem
schreibtisch und die zugeschalteten
bürgermeister sind begeistert
hoffentlich hat jemand den tunnels
bescheid gesagt
das wetter bleibt auch morgen trocken
und warm mehr dazu gleich von özden
terli um 22 uhr ist der kollege claus
kleber für sie da und morgen an dieser
stelle petra gerster die freut sich auf
sie für heute und vom gesamten team
herzlichen dank für ihr großes interesse
machen sie sich wo immer das geht einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter große trockenheit
herrscht weiterhin und teilweise auch
extreme dürre bis 1,8 meter tiefe im
gesamten april ist kaum regen gefallen
sie sehen ist hier besonders nach osten
und süden hin tiefrot eingefärbt die
außergewöhnliche dürre die herrscht
daran ändert sich wenig von norden her
kommt zwar kühlere luft mit wolken ins
land aber regen ist kaum dabei vor allem
im süden da erreicht uns weiterhin sehr
warme luft in der nacht kommen die
wolken bis etwa in den norden
reingezogen ansonsten bleibt es stern
klar und trocken bei 1 bis 10 grad
und morgen dann im nordwesten viel
sonnenschein sonst nach süden viele
wolken und auch im osten und der winter
hat auf nordwest gedreht und ist nicht
mehr ganz so durch insgesamt bleibt es
trocken temperaturen dazu bis 25 grad im
südwesten und 13 bis 16 grad entlang der
küsten die nächsten tage am samstag
weiterhin warm bis 23 grad mit
sonnenschein vor allem im westen
ja und dann gibt es wieder sommertage um
25 grad im süden aber schauer und
gewitter ein schöner abend